this is not the metroplex you grew up
with but in robot form
he's pretty bad ass
[Music]
what's up guys it's me bobby and we are
back with what i believe is the world's
first unboxing of
transformers legacy's metroplex the
reimagining of metroplex from what we
used to know him from g1 autobot city
back in the day now he is an excavator
an excavator metroplex
is a construction truck
that can dig up dirt
who knew we needed it
but hasbro said we do
as we say here on the channel
it is what it is
but let's go look at the box first and
foremost here this is very 1980s
graphics it reminds me of like poison or
cinderella or a little bit of bon jovi
back in the day the font the graphics
the colors that's what we're talking
about here so we've got uh metroplex in
his robot form just kicking ass with his
excavator tool here in his arms this is
a titan class this is the largest of the
titan class here we have scorpinox we
have the arc and we have metroplex he
stands the tallest um really close to
scorpinox but i would say give the edge
to metroplex okay moving around to the
side of the box here we got rod of us
prime various different characters and
we go to the back and we get to see how
he transforms into him in three
different modes robot form combat mode
and excavator mode if you look at this
uh closely you might think that he's
bending over waiting for a thermometer
that could be the case we do not know
but there is no thermometer that came
inside the box that we saw at least so
but it does look a little bit odd the
combat mode he looks pretty cool a
little stock here not as tall as he is
in robot form but you see his excavator
tools are now part of his arms here
which is actually pretty wicked i like
that and then of course in robot form so
we'll transform all these in just a bit
but i think this is sort of like the
bonus transforming feature as we
mentioned because there is no manual to
how to do that you have to kind of
figure it out yourself
let's get down to talking about
metroplex here as i mentioned before a
reimagining you got to be an open mind
when you're looking at this metroplex
here but i like what they did with it
the colors are absolutely awesome on
this um different from what i'm used to
seeing with the blue white red black a
little bit tinge of gold and gray does
make him look very patriotic as an
american i have to say
but on the face here we do have uh very
similar in terms of what metroplex looks
like in g1 we've got that very similar
sculpt on that of course but the new
coloring goes all the way through um he
feels really robust and very um solid
the details through the chest with the
gold inlay right here with the little
red uh dot right here looks fantastic
gives it a nice peel with the waist
right here with the red highlights there
and the gold around that looks
absolutely cool the blue inlay right
there
is his forearms look great the hands are
articulating you can turn them around
you can move the thumb digit but the
fingers move as a hole for the four
fingers there so keep that in mind that
helps you be able to hold on to this
tool it did take us a while to figure
this one out because it's all about
weight and balance because this is heavy
this could hurt somebody that's why this
is for 15 plus
because
this could be used as a weapon sorry
guys it's really it's really solid and
uh he's also really big as well so
yeah you gotta move around his feet his
legs a little bit so everything stays in
place but once you get it there that's
what you get right here so it's pretty
cool what do you guys think not too bad
right absolutely pretty wicked okay so
that's essentially a metroplex we'll
turn around on the back so you guys can
see what it looks like behind
this is where you can hold his excavator
tool here this goes on the back sort of
like how a samurai will hold a sword
you'll get that same look with this
metroplex version here which looks
absolutely good as a matter of fact
that's how i prefer this one here um
as you can see it's rocking a little bit
it's not the most secure thing it's not
going to fall off but again you have to
redistribute the weight on the body to
make it stand up the legs do articulate
turn around which is great so there's a
lot of articulation going on here with
him so that's what it looks like in
robot mode let's go into combat mode
right now
[Music]
do you realize there's nothing here in
the manual about this at all
young figured this out by actually
looking at the box so that's what you
guys can have to do at home unless
hasbro does print out in the manual how
to do this it doesn't look easy
not at all
so a couple things to take note of here
um there are some differences from the
box in terms of the graphics and the
paint than what you're going to get in
person case in point right here on the
box these are gold on each side but in
in person it's actually all black so
that is different from the model here i
kind of wish it was gold i do like the
gold and black separation it gives it a
nice a little bit of pop to the color
which is great
but overall it's okay i really like this
portion here with the gold inlay i think
the gold just really makes it come alive
in a very interesting way here
really good paint throughout that
but yeah the arms this is definitely
going to take some length just go to the
side here you're going to get to see how
long this is when it protrudes out so if
we were to use our display case here we
would definitely have to take away a
shelf and then
this may hit a glass door so this might
be something that you need to consider
when you're going to display if you want
to display them in this way
yeah you could probably point it down
like that if you want to do that just to
save some space it doesn't look like
it's cool when you have him down like
that it looks a little bit like
he's not really combat ready but it is
what it is okay so let's go around the
back here we can see some of the details
the autobot logo is right here um so i
guess in combat mode you don't know if
he's an autobot or decepticon so he can
kind of get in there and do his damage
and then when you look from behind after
you got your ass kicked you go oh [ __ ]
he's on autobot all right so now that
he's done kicking ass we're going to
transform into excavator mode so he can
take it up the
[Music]
you see what i'm talking about
he literally looks bent over
yeah
there's that joke they talk about thanos
and ant-man
i'm just saying
things in cybertron happen
right
right in the scooper yeah there he is
he's on
all fours that's his transformation and
then of course you've got this excavator
tool here and uh somewhat articulate but
there is a bonus feature to this because
you would fold these down but if you
want to carry them around
these become a handle so you can walk
around and carry your excavator to
wherever you want to go
all jokes aside though we're having fun
here because it's 15 and over who's
gonna buy this thing we can have some
fun talking about this let's look at him
as excavator mode um
it's okay honestly speaking
it doesn't wow me to be frank with you
this doesn't wow me in this mode i think
in combat mode and robot mode he looks
really kind of cool this
seems to me like
okay we need him to transform into
something but
does an excavator actually look like
this per se
i don't know
that feels like there's a lot of gaps in
between here there's things that pieces
that just don't look like it becomes
like a part of a truck you know again
again this is cybertronian so there's
gonna be some liberties in terms of
design
but
you know what i mean it just seems to me
he's on all fours and you got these
wheels here you got these tractor wheels
here but these don't these don't roll
per se there's small little wheels
underneath
that are a little bit tight but they'll
roll a little bit so keep that in mind
then you've got these guns here that go
flip up and down so we can go into
combat mode you know he's still got to
shoot when he's in excavator mode we've
got this piece here it rolls it makes
sounds
exciting this opens up claws
just digs
but does it bend down it does but you
got to hold this piece while you bend
him down it doesn't go down to the
ground because it's too short but it
does cover his backside a little bit so
if he wants a little bit of protection
he just brings his claw down in
happy
sad this arm does turn a little bit
not a one it's not 360. i would say
about 45 degrees there abouts but this
black piece will scrape
on this right here a little bit so it's
not going to scrape any paint off it's
black on black but something to keep in
mind if you do
hear that or feel it that's the reason
for it uh
there's his head right there
kind of peeking out
just
final thoughts as i mentioned in the
beginning of this video in robot 4
metroplex looks badass
but in excavator mode
not so much i mean look at scorpio for a
second in robot form impressive
and he transforms into a scorpion and he
looks great is that in that as well
because skylinks as a space shuttle can
do various different things with
skylinks then you've got the arc which
granted never transformed in g1 but they
did make some amendments to it and it
looks cool it looks really interesting
and i teletran one it had a lot of
easter eggs inside of it there's a lot
of cool things to this titan class that
hasbro did which
i thought was really wicked
but
the biggest of them all
metroplex what used to be the autobot
city
is
there's no easter eggs whatsoever and
they made them a construction truck
it's not
at all what we grew up with and it's
okay to make some amendments i get it i
mean these things happen of course you
want to kind of refresh transformers as
we could go into the years but
this feels the weakest of the titan
class
we were hoping was going to be the best
of the titan class anyway those are my
thoughts on this let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below do
you agree with me or are you gonna pick
this up you think this is the best of
this entire series
i would love to hear from you guys on
that like always follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on this channel like the
video hit that notification bell we got
a lot of great content coming your way
here at geek culture take care stay safe
and i'll chat to you soon bye
foreign